moving around all right and I could see
Rick over there you see he's kind of
getting self situated look we're in this
room over here are we playing joust no
we're not playing joust but that was a
good guess all right so uh you can see
like you actually kind of get this
really good sensation of like being up
high and sometimes that's actually
pretty scary if you're afraid of heights
but it's a really really kind of cool
feeling to be in there and the sauce I'm
here but I've lost my hands oh no he's
lost his hands okay well then go I got
no hand so I'm gonna be a little
defenseless in this up all right so i
won't take too much advantage of you out
there but look I can kind of throw stuff
oh you've actually kind of that you
uh-huh look at that Oh what is that so
sauce maybe you can switch between first
and third persons are third person view
now yeah so you can kind of see my body
so this is supposed to be kind of a
battle situation and what we really
wanted to do is be able to show you
different characters how you could
control a character so the hands that
get tracked and then the head tracks and
so you should be watching sauces screen
maybe bet more than my all right well
I've got a disk in my hand over here
what am I gonna do in that maybe I'll
toss it over here what yeah maybe goes
try and hit my defenseless body here
okay let's see let's see thing again i
can still duck oh there we go that's not
fair all right there we go all right how
about I set one up right in front of me
and just kind of whack it oh oh yes
but I can can I do a bank shot that's
kind of actually kind of tricky I'd see
oh so close okk you do get more shots to
use a bank shot more points to bank
shine see we'll just kind of do
continuous bank shots over here until
something hits oh come on haha oh yeah
just family I'm gonna put it on Rick's
hands there we go there's a shot but
that wasn't it you guys get the idea so
well i hope this tech demo did is just
give you a little taste of what
playstation vr is about okay that's done
right now check out this legendary
masterpiece of light and sound thanks
guys